you've divined these six pillars that  kind of encapsulate what it means to you  know have optimal Hormone Health so  maybe we can kind of go through them  periodum yeah the six pillars the first  two are diet and exercise and they kind  of have the  um they're the most powerful pillars if  you will  and then the last four I used  alliteration so you have uh your stress  optimization so you you want to have  some effort in life you want to have  something that you're working towards  you also have sleep and that's quality  and quantity of sleep you have sunlight  and that really just means the outdoors  it encompasses cold exposure heat  exposure even moving your body and being  exposed to the elements and then you  have spirit and that's just the  self-actualization piece on Maslow's  hierarchy of needs and everybody has  um you know spiritual or metaphysical  Health which is important because that's  what their purpose is yeah